KORY JEFFREY:
Welcome, everybody.
We are on site at Founder
World in San Francisco.
Joining me in the studio
right now is Sang Lee.
He's the CEO of Dark Matter.
Welcome to the studio, Sang.
SANG LEE: Thanks for having me.
KORY JEFFREY: Awesome.
So let's talk a little
bit about Dark Matter.
What is it?
What do you do?
SANG LEE: So Dark Matter
is a SaaS-based platform
that allows asset managers,
like fund managers, venture
capitalists, hedge funds to
basically manage, optimize,
and access new investors
in the investor world.
KORY JEFFREY: Interesting.
That's pretty cool.
So how does that work?
SANG LEE: So when an actual
asset manager raises capital,
it's not dissimilar to
startups raising capital.
So a lot of people
think that fund managers
are born with money.
They actually go through
the exact same process
a startup would.
So they have to
identify investors,
see which investors
are right for them.
And then, unlike startups,
they have a very complicated
onboarding process of
identifying them, qualifying
them, making them
sign documents,
and making sure they're part
of the system, if you will.
That process is done
exclusively offline today
right now by people
and spreadsheets.
And we're bringing that to
the cloud for the first time.
So asset managers like
BlackRock and a lot
of these other firms you
may have heard of still
use staff and paperwork to
identify these investors.
We're going to bring that
to a data driven model.
KORY JEFFREY: So
that's interesting.
So it sounds like a very
old style marketplace
or, I guess, segment that's
coming into the new tech world.
Are there any other sort
of trends in that space
of changes in tech?
SANG LEE: Yeah, absolutely.
So I think a lot of
the technology that's
been developed on
Wall Street primarily
were siloed for each firm.
So they developed a
lot of legacy software
that was ideal for one firm
but nobody else can use.
So you had these massive
software development companies
that had $5 million
contracts and would
develop one piece of
software for one firm,
but that wouldn't
work anywhere else.
What we see is that a lot of
large financial institutions
are migrating to the cloud.
And this is going to
require a lot of change
and a lot of capital invested.
But at the same
time, what we think
is the positive
in that regard is
that it's going to promote a
lot more transparency into Wall
Street.
When you don't have
siloed off information,
what you kind of
force upon people
is being transparent
and forthcoming
with the information
that they have.
KORY JEFFREY:
That's pretty cool.
So you guys are here today.
There's thousands of
people walking around.
You guys are set up with a
booth talking about Dark Matter.
What is it that you're hoping
to get out of the two days?
What attracted you
to Founder World?
SANG LEE: You know, what's
interesting is we obviously
attend events like this.
Some of the key things
that I like to take away
are when people
hate our products
because it gives me
a perspective on what
we need to improve and
what we need to change.
Being based in New
York, obviously, we
don't get out here as
often as we'd like.
But we obviously love
that pure technology angle
that San Francisco
can kind of bring us
in terms of our business
model as well as our products.
So we hope to connect with
a lot of like-minded people,
as well as
potentially investors.
KORY JEFFREY: That's right.
And there's of them here today.
SANG LEE: Yeah, absolutely.
KORY JEFFREY: So other than your
core business and the cloud,
we talked there's a lot
of technology here today.
What excites you in
the technology world?
SANG LEE: I think the
advent of technology
itself in financial
services is something
that really gets me up in the
morning because technology
itself, while it can be
fallible, most times, people
can't screw with it.
And when you think about that
and you think about Wall Street
and how vilified it's become
over the last 10 years,
it's quite something
that's really, really sad.
Because financial
services in and of itself
is supposed to be about value
transferring from me to you,
and doing well by
doing well for you.
That's really the genesis
of the whole thing.
And Wall Street created
this environment
where things are
done in back rooms
without technology
over phone calls,
without people being
accountable for their actions.
And for the first
time, I think what
we're seeing is not firms
building technology,
but rather technology
firms that are
entering financial
services, which
I think is very, very exciting.
KORY JEFFREY:
That's pretty cool.
Do you have a favorite
Google technology?
SANG LEE: You know, we started
our business off of Google,
as many startups do.
So there's so many things that I
like about the Google platform.
But particularly, we use a
lot of the Google Analytics.
So Google Analytics has been
kind of the bread and butter,
I think, of many, many startups.
But it really helps
us understand our core
constituents, how
they behave, and how
we can improve our business.
KORY JEFFREY: That's awesome.
Well, thank you very
much for joining me.
And thank you guys
for joining me.
My name is Kory.
We're on site at Founder
World in San Francisco.
[MUSIC PLAYING]